NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
POPULARITY.
>> Bret: AMY KELLOGG COME
ALIVE IN MOSCOW.
THANK YOU.
LET'S GET REACTION TO THE NEWS
INVOLVING RUSSIA, THE LATEST TO
THE INVESTIGATION SURROUNDING
RUSSIA IN THE U.S.
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN CHUCK GRASSLEY AND
MEMBER LINDSEY GRAHAM.
I SAT DOWN WITH THEM THIS
AFTERNOON IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM ON
CAPITOL HILL AND STARTED BY
ASKING ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NEW SANCTIONS
AGAINST RUSSIA.
>> GLAD TO KNOW IT'S HAPPENING
AND SECONDLY, BECAUSE OF THE
TORT
2016 ELECTION OF A GOOD REASON
FOR DOING IT BUT THERE'S PLENTY
OF REASON FOR DOING OTHERWISE.
ALL YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IS
UKRAINE AND THEIR INTERFERENCE
IN THE BALTICS.
GEORGIA AND CRIMEA AND ALL THAT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO RECREATE A
SOVIET STATE AND WE HAVE GOT TO
PUT A STOP TO IT.
>> I CAN'T SAY MUCH BETTER.
98-2 VOTE IN THE SENATE.
WE CAN'T AGREE ON MUCH OF
ANYTHING BUT 98 SENATORS VOTED
FOR THE SANCTIONS.
UP UNTIL TODAY THEY HAD NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
CLEARLY THE ASSASSINATION IN
GREAT BRITAIN HAD AN EFFECT
HERE.
THIS WAS A NERVE AGENT
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY.
CLEARLY RUSSIA WAS INVOLVED
HERE.
I'M VERY PLEASED.
BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE.
>> Bret: YOU ON THE COMMITTEE
HAVE RELEASED A SERIES OF
LETTERS TODAY CALLING FOR A
SPECIAL COUNSEL, ANOTHER SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
WHY?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST TO
YOU THAT YOU USE THE WORD
SPECIAL COUNSEL BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT IT IS.
WE ARE THINKING IN TERMS OF A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO WORK WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF CONFIDENCE
IN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S WORK.
WE KNOW HE'S A GOOD PERSON.
WE KNOW HE IS DOING GOOD WORK.
HE DIGS IN DEEP.
HE'S GOT A STAFF OF MAYBE 400
BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF WORKING WITH
PEOPLE THAT HAVE LEFT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
HE CAN ONLY BRING IN THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY IN
GOVERNMENT TO INVESTIGATE.
THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL WORKING IN
A TEAM, I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
WORD TEAM, WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, WILL GIVE
THEM THE TOOLS HE NEEDS TO GET
ALL THE INFORMATION THAT WE ARE
ASKING HIM TO GET.
WE SENT HIM 30 QUESTIONS WE WANT
INVESTIGATED.
>> Bret: >> Bret: THERE'S
>> Bret: >> Bret: THERE'A
>> Bret: >> Bret: THERE'L
>> Bret: >> Bret: THERE'T
>> Bret: >> Bret: THERE'O
>> Bret: >> Bret: THERE'F
QUESTIONS IN HERE.
ARE YOU SEEING THINGS THAT ARE
RED FLAGS FOR YOU, THAT YOU'VE
SEEN THAT ARE NOT GETTING
ANSWERED?
>> NUMBER ONE, CHAIRMAN GRASSLEY
HAS DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF
LOOKING AT ALL THINGS RUSSIA.
WE HAVE HAD HEARINGS IN OUR
COMMUNITY ABOUT HOW RUSSIA
OPERATES.
WE HAVE BROUGHT IN SALLY YATES
AND JOHN CLAPPER AND A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATION WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
WE HAVEN'T FOUND ANY EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BUT MUELLER IS DOING
HIS JOB.
THE CHAIRMAN AND I HAVE LOOKED
CLOSE AT THE FBI INVESTIGATION
OF THE CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL AND
I HAVE COME AWAY BELIEVING IT
WAS SHODDILY DONE.
THERE WERE CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
IN POLITICAL BIAS THAT MAY HAVE
RESULTED IN GIVING CLINTON A
PASS.
THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS PAID FOR
BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
FUSION GPS, MR. CHRISTOPHER
STEELE HAD ASSOCIATES IN RUSSIA
THEY COULD HAVE EASILY
COMPROMISED HIM.
WE BELIEVE THE FISA WARRANT
PROCESS WAS ABUSED.
THE REASON WE WANT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL AS I THINK CRIMES MAY
HAVE BEEN COMMITTED.
MR. CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS SUED
IN MAY OF 2017 IN GREAT BRITAIN
FOR LIBEL
FOR LIBEL.
SOMEONE SUED HIM IN BRITISH
COURT.
IN RESPONSE TO THE LAWSUIT HE
ADMITTED IN BRITISH COURT THAT
HE HAD TALKED TO MEDIA OUTLETS
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016 ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
THE P.I. TOLD THE FISA COURT ALL
THROUGH 2016 THAT MR. CHRISTOPHR
STEELE HAD NO CONTACTS AT
ALL WITH THE MEDIA WHEN IT COMES
TO SHOPPING AROUND THE DOSSIER.
WE HAVE A FILING IN BRITISH
COURT FOR A LAWYER FOR
MR. STEELE WHO ADMITS TO TALKING
TO THE WORLDWIDE MEDIA IN
SEPTEMBER OF THE SAME THE FBI
WAS USING HIM AS A CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANT.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO LOOK AND SEE
WHETHER OR NOT, WHO HE IS LYING
TO.
>> WE WILL GIVE HIM THE TOOLS TO
DO IT BECAUSE THEY CANNOT BE
COUNTED ON TO INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES.
IT'S KIND OF COMMON SENSE.
IF YOU DO SOMETHING WRONG, YOU
DON'T HAVE THE FOX GUARDING THE
CHICKEN HOUSE.
>> THE NUMBER FOUR PICK ORSON --
NUMBER FOUR PERSON, BRUCE OHR'S
WIFE WORKED FOR FUSION GPS.
THE INFORMANT THE FBI WAS USING
ON THE PAYROLL OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THERE IS NO IN THE WORLD
HE SHOULD HAVE INTERACTED WITH
MR. STEELE BECAUSE HIS WIFE
WORKED FOR THE SAME
ORGANIZATION.
SOMEBODY OTHER THAN THE PEOPLE
IN CHARGE TODAY NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT THEY DID YESTERDAY.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK
ANDREW MCCABE SHOULD BE FIRED
BEFORE HE RETIRES?
>> I AM NOT SURE I WANT TO MAKE
THAT JUDGMENT RIGHT NOW.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK IT COULD
HAPPEN?
>> I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, AND THEY HAVE
FOUND SOMETHING GROSSLY WRONG.
I'M NOT GOING TO DRAW A LINE ON
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE ABOUT IT.
>> Bret: SOMETHING COULD
HAPPEN.
>> WE HAVE RAISED ENOUGH
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME AND I SUGGEST
THAT HE OUGHT TO BE FIRED.
>> THE PUNISHMENT FOR VIOLATING
THE LAW SHOULD BE YOU LOSE YOUR
JOB.
IF HE IN FACT DID AUTHORIZE FBI
AGENTS TO TALK TO THE MEDIA AND
LIED ABOUT IT.
>> Bret: SEEING WHAT YOU'VE
SEEN, YOU THINK HE DID.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
HERE'S WHAT I DO KNOW.
THE FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WERE CORRUPT WHEN IT
CAME TO HANDLING THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION OF CLINTON AND THE
ENTIRE FISA WARRANT APPLICATION
PROCESS WAS ABUSED.
ONE LAST THING.
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT SEEMS TO CARE
ABOUT THIS.
>> WHY DID WE START OUT WITH
THIS?
TRUMP-RUSSIA WAS THE START BUT
YOU FOLLOW THE FACTS AND THE
FACTS LED US TO THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS DONE IN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
TODAY I WAS CRITICIZING MY
COMMITTEE BY DEMOCRATS, WHY ARE
ADMINISTRATION?
WELL, IF THERE IS POLITICAL
INTERFERENCE IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE FBI IN ONE
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE WERE LOOKING INTO, WOULDN'T
IT BE NATURAL THAT IT'S WRONG IN
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION?
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY STORIES ABOUT A MAJOR
SHAKE-UP IN HIS ADMINISTRATION
ARE WRONG, OVERWRITTEN.
CLEARLY HE IS CONSIDERING SOME
ADDITIONAL CHANGES, INCLUDING
WHAT'S ALREADY HAPPENED WITH
REX TILLERSON.
IF HE DID FIRE JEFF SESSIONS,
HOW WOULD THAT GO OVER IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE?
>> I WOULD ONLY ANSWER THIS WAY.
UNLESS YOU PUSH ME ON IT.
I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD BE
FIRED.
>> Bret: I WILL PUSH YOU
WANTED.
>> THE CHAIRMAN HAS DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB GETTING NOMINEES
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE WITH A LOT
OF OBSTRUCTION.
IF YOU HAD TO REPLACE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
WITH SOMEBODY NEW, IT WOULD BLOW
THE PLACE UP.
IT WOULD BE SEEN AS AN EFFORT TO
UNDERMINE THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK JEFF SESSIONS HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB.
>> Bret: HAVE YOU HEARD PLANS
TO DO IT?
>> I HAVE PEOPLE IN JOURNALISM
LIKE YOU ASKING THIS AND I GIVE
THE SAME ANSWER TO YOU.
REMEMBER, THIS ADMINISTRATION
HAS ENOUGH TO DO.
THERE'S 100 VACANCIES IN THE
COURT NOW THAT MY COMMITTEE HAS
TO DEAL WITH.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO DEAL WITH
A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE GOING
FAIRLY SMOOTHLY.
>> ONE LAST THING ABOUT WHAT
BROUGHT US HERE TODAY.
IF THE SHOE WERE ON THE OTHER
FOOT, CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW THE
MEDIA WOULD BE REACTING.
IF YOU FOUND THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR OF AN INVESTIGATION
HAD A POLITICAL BIAS AGAINST
CLINTON AND FOR TRUMP, THAT IF
THERE WAS A DOSSIER USED BY THE
FBI TO GET A FISA WARRANT AND
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY PAID TO A
FOREIGN AGENT TO GO TO RUSSIA TO
GET INFORMATION ON
HILLARY CLINTON, HOW THEY WOULD
BE BEHAVING TODAY.
ALL I CAN SAY TO MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES, I HAVE SUPPORTED
MUELLER HAVING THE INDEPENDENCE
TO DO HIS JOB.
BUT IF YOU DON'T THINK IT'S
WRONG FOR THE FBI TO USE OF PAID
POLITICAL INFORMANT AND PRESENT
A DOSSIER THAT'S BEEN
UNVERIFIED, THEN I DISAGREE.
THE BOTTOM LINE HERE, FOLKS,
WHAT THE FBI AND DOJ DID IN
TERMS OF INVESTIGATING CLINTON
AND THE INITIAL INVESTIGATION
REGARDING THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, IT
REALLY BOTHERS ME, AND I WANT
SOMEBODY OTHER THAN A POLITICIAN
LOOKING AT IT.
>> Bret: CHANCES YOU CAN GET A
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN ADDITION TO
WHAT'S ALREADY THERE?
>> I WILL BE SHOCKED IF SOMEBODY
DOESN'T SEE THE INHERENT
CONFLICT IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REGARDING INVESTIGATING
ITSELF.
HIGH PROBABILITY.
>> I'M GOING TO USE AS MUCH
LEVERAGE AS I CAN AND I THINK I